for dinner it's a meager rich teriyaki
salmon with a buckwheat soba noodle
salad brimming with healthy greens first
job the teriyaki marinade for the salmon
Tilly can help they'll be the salmon
please write teriyaki delicious sticky
sweet salmon okay first of all I'd like
you a little season on the salmon please
with salt and pepper
thank you won't you just slice the
garlic one in front two behind yeah oh
and a bit faster than your age ah
good girl thank you right garlic in with
the ginger so we're gonna make a
marinade
okay you know what a marinade is it's
what you cook then that's right so they
start off with soy sauce 3 tablespoons
what good good good
this is rice wine also known as mirror
in pure gold beautiful little touch I
want you to rub a salmon in the marinade
you can get chance to do this the night
before the salmon actually changes color
but it's fine even with 10 or 15 minutes
before you start cooking it does it
ginger and garlic give it a different
taste
ja what it helps improve the taste while
we cook it have this really nice glaze
on there okay right let's put that in
the fridge to marinate
but teriyaki Salmons marinating time to
get on with the noodle and vitamin
packed veg and seed salad soba noodles
now this color because they're made out
of buckwheat okay then we gonna drop
them in so nice and carefully if you
slide them that way and then you go like
that in your hand I'll show you that and
then look hold them like that and drop
them into the pan okay got them yeah
okay so hold on tight off yeah
nice do they take longer to cook they're
normally actually take this week five
minutes
now are they please okay Brady crunchy
now carrot and kale I'll show you a
really quick way of slice and carrot
ribbons so you just come down that's
right off you go
there we go nice big long ribbons sugar
snap peas in okay into the ladles up -
oh thank you
wake up daddy next tale now you know how
good that is for you right yes kale in
fine how the ribbons oh that's nice you
you okay like some salt pepper in a wet
cat ribbons go in good girl don't forget
any like you did so excuse me and
because we've shaved them really thinly
like this how long do you think they're
gonna take to cook it doesn't get me
doesn't it now we're gonna drain the
noodles that is beautiful
see how the curls and the vegetables for
too long would they just go a bit hard
they'll go soft and mushy okay and then
we drop the noodles in but now I'm gonna
make those noodles taste even better
I'd like you to put a little bit of salt
pepper on there for me please next
it's begging us to watch your fingers
please put the dressing on that ginger
goes in you can't be nice it's gonna be
like a multi-season salad what's that a
little smell that's right accessing oil
a touch discuss me over okay why it's
why vinegar a little splash okay and
then finally and have a touch of soy
sauce and let you just like in please
that's it one little final ingredient
who's favors that Jack's Holly's and my
slice into strips okay no chop that oh
how is that get don't you to sprinkle
that on top of the noodles and I'll
squeeze the lemon juice oh excuse me
who was it had a lemon shower today soba
noodle salad is ready now we'll get on
and cut the salmon oh it looks good
doesn't it right pan nice and hot
what did I show you when you put fish in
the pan which way did you put in you put
it in and skinning down that's right and
then there's the pan there and you put
it in there and you lay away from you
you lay it toward you what happens yeah
splash that's right so take your time
[Music]
go
my last one Jojo very slickly plus
they're fresh nice a nice little bit of
gin John that now mr. garlic smell the
run next year will be the flavor
nice color on the salmon
nice and crispy the front
and I thought you support the rest of
Monet's over for me please
[Music]
not
okay now that sounds a little glaze now
well done
you're getting good at this cooking
stuff you know that would you like to be
a chef when you grow up ready um one day
[Music]
make the coffee
I do the cakes so it's gonna have like
scrambled eggs for breakfast so you
already fought this house
yeah we're planning it the other night
when we couldn't sleep
I'm who's gonna be the head chef and
who's gonna be the sous chef no we're
not gonna do that cuz you've ever got
different roles in it
Oh it'sit's well for now yeah but then
we don't need anybody ask the prop from
me enhancer no other people I was nice
it sounds amazing get the spoon here
like this okay and just tilt the pan
I'll tilt the pan you plays this our
point please no very my darling already
do you keep the ginger too perfect
what was your favorite type of salmon
when you're an adult salmon fish cakes
you like those how's that experiences
about you to carry that very carefully
over to the table okay and I'll carry
your noodles ready let's go well done
some fascinated with this rational you
and Jacko go open yeah
participant this is my ultimate healthy
dinner it's fresh home-cooked and full
of goodness but most importantly it's
absolutely delicious
they're calling mom dinner so we have a
delicious teriyaki salmon with soba
noodles please look and sound fun
[Music]